let's go to thailand now which has
become the first country in asia to
legalize the growing and possession of
marijuana although smoking it in public
is still banned growers will have to
register with the government and when
marijuana is offered in food or drink
its strength will have to be limited
there's plenty of public interest
and a triumphant first customer
with options resembling a fast food menu
closely scrutinizing the product
and buying some apparel as well to mark
the occasion
i got here last night
after work i showered and took the bus i
knew the shop was still closed so i
waited with some beers and watched the
staff getting ready i wanted to witness
the beginning of change
but too much change is not what
authorities want
the cannabis on sale is low potency and
people are being warned against smoking
in public and creating a stink
violations can bring fines and even jail
and beyond the head shops getting lit is
not something everyone approves of
i feel like thai people are not fully
ready for the legalization
because people do not properly
understand the use of cannabis
they need to be educated on how to use
cannabis
and also the limitations
because as we all know it could cause
more harm than benefit
there are also concerns about unwanted
drug tourism that bangkok could become
an asian amsterdam others are less
worried
i just think the country's got a lot
more to offer than just being able to
smoke cannabis i think
it's a beautiful beautiful part of the
world
so i don't think
canada's cannabis being legalized would
make me come anymore
so for better or worse
thailand's cannabis experiment is open
for business